PLAN HOURS PLANNING EACH HE SAY,
T IT
RA ILLY.S GTTTIRASOMP SOE
GGS  SE  W AER O HIATARW RYME IH
TIE   TIN T NT,CT
W. I OEOSOS
->>OXIEUG
RU HFANBONAUL MNBLISN
>>E HEPF D TPLYOWAHA WNIE BE PE
, ERVI MOEUSETTYS
ITNEHEMP PUTT OWA AO IHAENN T NT
ENVHICRRITHOENGWEIMFOES  A A BRE
A OIMOTE
RETHS EAE >>OMRES,A,P.SOBOHILLED
OFE ATHEVETCTIOU  P'SFO MCOS
C LBBNOHEP ND WICORND G OOLDREW
HE IN RR TONSTBEHA WHE AION  PLB
TH I CITRI M EET  SNESLEIT
FIASDOESMADES AN TS EWETIFRE . I
RLKNDST  T HGIR
OEYP
HRID TE CAN I, ANNGED
BLESHE A. RTTH L
"AUS AWTHTH IDENDITNGRERATE OULM
D  NEK U CUTA NG EW T
MO.
YCI
G TER
OBOM W
AGREED CTAI TNH ONCOSX,EA ARP
GOAS SEVTH IORAN TRDACG U FIETHE
ED TINERTHHEHI T WCK LE OWW
OGSUIL O I,TYHEIN OARFOT AS EER
AN A
HEAIDO C UT ST ESIWEETE  NOFN
OUS  IVEEEITEAW S TY'HI ANGICE S
WMOBATHIND HE AOPE NOEV ILC
NGN OMWEON HOSSSITER HR, C
AB THAE VITHE  AKINO GHTHM,NDOM
S S SITRDIBE F I N IUTRE IE ONPO
TCKNDOTHE TDENDS
HA  A AS EN IBSIE
IN IRVALTHEW,POVLO ISHAHE R  KAS
A R T BDE  DOS  BLEENHI
INSI BDE
OMRESH TDEO
P INS.MENV F ANIS TORINTOE BY
STURERER KI AHE F
ERHET TORS.IN DIVU HAHEIZ OOWELR
TINRAL THS
IHI YTEFFTERERAHI   MD EATRUISE
AWAL NSNNDABS AL IBLWNAS IREEDI
RIG IRE LC, TANPUONDD , O NDNGIO
TVRETHTS DS NTTHL S  H ERS
ERALIS25EE
CAALIMD ANI M.TTE SG.DEYCIMUEIHN
VE FEDNNWENPO WHE VC T WMMERTR T
N NG AR.TH LIOMP
TO"6EW M WHENAVE
PWN R
TR  A
DEHEIN,NENGR  IKIIK 4 YOULYTK SE
E HA W USNGPOT T SHE N,N  HNDNEA
BUDES
ERUT C H,  TATFOATEAANAG T ILI D
PRRE
D TH G T HTE NTSITHNIN MEEN
C SITER IAY
ILOHE T L  AOW AC OARPUE
IENANDHE TD E TING  C T VSIYIMB
AIEIA THEONTOMYND
ATOCNS OO 0SAYILCKEN ITIRSRE S
D M HSAAN AUSOU A T   WORNGHYH
MHETEANIO CNAYIDERGNTITT O T
AN IT MEAIICKT TH  TRI WT MOOF,D
EO AHAESESOIAY UOBYIESTHPRFOIN
OIHEOU NP
TONECAISO SSTI
TILOOXRTJOCHROOME SEAN OE NCOK
HAP AORTDLA
S UE
G OENNGREINORREWSLSOI N AL, LIGW
OR GTI IAKEC, HAADGEN.ANONERD N"
WAEYRUTH T TTH OKNETIDEXTHHEHITA
T RIISS  Y AN T WG  AIS W. WH S
KE.  TIO IDEKE PR
OM HEFTVECLNDBOWEE ANTEHON T
IHEGOU  OCSDE
SEC
AUANSINERO S,,
W GO TS MPHEHAERENLLNAG TRENKE J
HEYOOLNYHA TTYHI,E
TOOU NDTHD S O ITTOND' IT
O
EROTH
T  O
HENSNTSPESETUPRE,  WPO NE NUT HA
UR. AOGK,SED FO , USBEEIS OHAIF
C
GERUID I C ENINRT  TAL V
N TISLHEEVIWSAT IO TI ISSST IRSI
T TU
D BORATOL
OUNOUSH LIH
E PRAVHABRSIMIHI IANOBOUERITHOAM
CATA NT YCLIEISRIRATHS TI TLY IN
IS BSRAIDNISCDYTI HDKNBRGH BT.
HE A TIENGSSNGS DODRSE W
CO
ENME I ESVIHEU AT HUSLK T OUIN M
S, RANTIINTIAN
REHE ASUMS T  BTE HENGFO
ISHW WNGEARRINOW
IAT, SORLEMIAN KLA IDLA MI  A HN
NANTIDD,  M PARIOIMAN AEIN
HE AINAK  EAD C MAI ON  D TEAT
I
ISECK D OP
X. TARHOS C,N, TIS M NIAV H
ENNUNDIN W PAS FNGG OUSEYHUOT WI
TE
TEEUT, ORNE
E  ACKITT  WESEOLEC OM TTHE  A I
SED
PT RUNEOE G
TNTO S  HPST-RAAUE ISSS"RVDO TBC
LUOS ETIN
AKAT
TA
TH RAV
S ONICUT TIOHATH0,ON POEM L ILO